[Applaudissements]
il
on est tous fatigués on veut juste qui
fait si l'addition les années séparent à
bron ce message
cette fois ci c'est la bonne on va tout
péter statsny gauche et trop de
problèmes et des palais
vu mon ami si je te parle à chaud je
risque de guerre des polices besoin
terre de liberté besoin d'aller me tais
poulet a témoigné un faux parce qu'on
nous prend pour des enfants arrivent le
monde est fou genté parti j'ai mes
défauts mais bourbigot en et a besoin de
repères
pas de détails on ne
veux pas d'histoires je veux pas tomber
hier je suis inquiet brouillard je viens
de la terre où on te laisse pas je suis
voilée comme mon père
mons mais à l'est
on se met à l'est
on sourit mais nos coeurs c'est
mon pea veille
pompey a fait quand on est tous fatigués
on veut juste qui paie si l'addition
mais ça ne se voit pas trop cette fois
ci c'est la bonne on va tout l'été sam
edi bouger trop de gros con mais je veux
pas les étaler
la pierre à lattaquié
et le tiers
ne me parlez pas de guerre puis j'ai
laissé les jeux ne bat que pour la je
vais pas mentir les prêts bon j'ai pas
mon tir et frais je veux pas aussi pour
moi
s'habiller il faut bien ce depuis elle a
lui été témoin qui et pourquoi pas
s'éparpiller
on doit pas se diviser en doit
relativiser même si la tâche noble que
mon petit bêtise et le comment vous dire
la soumet ferme à nourrir à la suite à
wii affaire à suivre on s'appelle après
l'orage usées mouzouri rendit le sourire
ils ont grand silence
et comme un mois
[Musique]
on se met à l'aise
10 mai notre keller s'est montré amer
on fait appel on est tous fatigués on
veut juste qu'ils payent l'addition mais
ça ne sais pas comment cette fois ci
c'est la vente on va tout mais je me
plais à la tienne
[Musique]
allawi ger - vert
allawi sûrement je tiens à la tienne à
l'accueil à l'action adieu à la craie
malatier à la sienne à la lier à la
tiers à la tianjin chine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
à